there is no evidence to support that
well I I
hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
noted Democrat activist Jake Tapper is
still doing his thing over at the CNN
and this is a dad talking about his son
but it's also the president of the
United States talking about a potential
defendant in a case that his justice
department is Prosecuting also he was
about to plead guilty to some things
that he did wrong does the president
need to stop publicly saying his son did
nothing wrong
well look I think the president has been
very clear that he's going to let the
process play out
um what we do know is that through all
of the investigations in Congress uh
there are they're simply investigating a
private citizen Hunter Biden is not
running for president and Joe Biden is
running for president and yet and he is
the president and yet notwithstanding
all of the time effort and all of the
moving goal posts there's no evidence
connecting President Biden to any of his
son's business dealings and you can you
know you can sing all you want and make
all sorts of accusations but the fact of
the matter is that President Biden uh
there's been no evidence to show that
he's been involved in anything and so
Hunter Biden will be treated by the
Department of Justice as he should be
but Congress needs to stop investigating
a private citizen and uh stop this
fishing expedition to try to link
President Biden to Hunter Biden's
conduct when there is no evidence to
support that well I I
Devin Archer Hunter Biden's business
partner told you in closed door
testimony that Hunter would put his
father on speakerphone uh with while he
was meeting with his business associates
uh and this happened at least 20 times
and Archer told you that Hunter would
use these calls to send signals to his
business partners to create the
impression that his father was involved
and helpful to his business even if
you're right as as there has been no
establishment of any facts that Joe
Biden did anything as vice president or
president relatedly but shouldn't
President Biden have realized what
Hunter was doing here getting on the
phone talking speakerphone with his
business associates did he get the at
the very least show a major lapse in
judgment uh in a blind spot with his son
on and how he handled this